Continental Tire Coaches Corner the
proud exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive what you
drive how you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire calm
little tire for what you do and we make
way for Dave Roberts Dodgers manager
first concert you ever went to Dave new
addition new addition what's a new
addition and yeah I think it was new
addition and Karen white that's way back
best concert you ever went to the best
concert I've went to I think was just
recently why I saw maroon 5 at Dodger
Stadium
that without was very special John
Legend Dodger Stadium so those are kind
of one and two for me but do you go and
then you just say Dave Roberts Dodgers
manager then you're able to go you know
you're going into Dodger Stadium but the
Dodgers aren't playing so how do you
pull that off so that one was the Dodger
Galit so it was a special intimate
Dodger Stadium in centerfield and that's
that so that was kind I didn't have to
drop the de Vries commander card on that
one and the new addition I was kind of
back in the day den where it was like
the El DeBarge yeah buzz mustache and
the shag long hair those are those days
where you had to get a shirt or a show
for my parents
did you have that look I own that look
man yeah all right I got some good news
here to tell you I got a couple of
things for you do you know what the the
wine enthusiasts rating on your 2017 red
stitch Chardonnay is so I don't I should
do you want to know I do and if it's not
ninety if it's not ninety-three and
above that don't believe it
okay this score is not going to be
published until July first but I got
information I got information so you
this is this is your wine or you're part
of the group
owns red stitch given what is your
relationship with red stitch yeah I'm an
owner so me and a couple other guys are
families that we are it's this yes sir
okay 2017 red stitch chardonnay by the
way the Pinot and the calves are
wonderful and I and I would say that if
you weren't on the show
just receive ninety two points from wine
enthusiasts and the score won't be
published until July 1st so I just got
that information there so
congratulations and that's a that's a
great number that's a great number no it
is it is anything above 90 is an
excellent wine so 92 we will definitely
take you look throughout of it it's uh
I'm glad you enjoyed the Chardonnay and
did you say the Pinot or the cab the cab
okay alright so then I got to send you
some pinot noir as well and once again
you get no preferential treatment
because you know if this year ends like
last year then I gotta rip you so just
so you know I love the wine I appreciate
our friendship the wine doesn't hurt but
you know I gotta still do my job you're
dead dude I'm fair game okay here's the
other bit of information so I gave you
that information here's something that
maybe you didn't know this is only since
1900 best record by a manager in
baseball history minimum of 500 games
yes you're second on the list number one
Joe McCarthy who won 2100 games you've
won 342 so you got a chance
yes
there's nobody modern-era who's close to
you at winning 60% of your games it's
the second best record by a manager
since 1900 minimum 500 games no that's
great and I'll tell you though dad is
that what I tell my players every single
day what makes a good coach good place
is that we're fortunate to have good
players
all right the Padres drafted your son
Cole and did you did mom say you had to
draft your son
so my son preemptively said you better
not pull any strings or influence the
Dodgers to draft me because I would be
at nightmare for me so I made sure that
the Dodgers didn't drop them for sure
and for the Padres to drop them on his
own ability I was very proud of and I
had nothing to do with that so that was
a feather in his cap and we're very
proud of him do you know like let's say
your pitching staff was gonna face him
in a couple of years do you know his
scouting report and would you give
inside information to your pitchers when
they face your son absolutely I would go
this sounds like his nickname hard soft
away now something like that it house
them around it should be pretty high
here you know it's good you know I think
the thing is though damn is that if you
come into our Clubhouse it's uh you know
after a tough loss as a big win it's
very consistent and very steady so I
think that for me I think that people
that aren't with this everyday expect
more but I kind of really appreciate
that businesslike attitude and today
we're going to come in on a day game and
try to win a series and it's going to
kind of be that same methodical approach
and that's kind of how we play the game
explain this from a managerial
standpoint I don't mean to mate and make
light of it but Cody Bellinger leads the
league in hugs by women during games
here and it it's it's bordering on
getting a little silly trendy what do
you think of this phenomenon okay so you
know you look back at the 80s and I
recall vaguely
you know Morgana and doing that thing it
is kind of all fun and games and things
like that and I just think it just
speaks to obviously right now these are
these are minors and and it's innocent
right now I just think that in this
where we're at right now you know it can
turn a different direction and that's
where we got to be on guard and I'm
concerned for the players for co-teach
and not have to worry about people
coming in the stands and you just never
know people's motive so that's why I
yeah I think at first look you
want to kind of look at it softly but
you got to be really mindful of where
we're at in society sometimes a manager
has to read the room correctly and
sometimes you just say let me let that
guy be that guy and I don't know if
you're at that point with Cody Bellinger
where you just don't say anything as
opposed to you know giving him a tip or
something like that
wait what is your approach to as great
as Bellinger has been this year I think
there's a little bit of a lot of that of
just continued for for sure to let him
be himself I think for me it's more of
just continue to do what you've been
doing and you know you see guys now
intensely walking am walking I'm
pitching around them and I think that a
couple weeks ago I saw the frustration
and that sort of bleeds into anxiousness
and over aggressiveness to the next
at-bats and that's something that I want
I want to guard against and so now you
know you've got to take the game in
stride and understand there's a tactical
part of it and so not let that get you
and if he does that and continues to do
all the things that he's doing he's
gonna be fine Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
Dodgers manager Dave Roberts home runs
are up in Major League Baseball because
of what the number one reason I know
where you want me to go I know you want
me to go with this III got the baseballs
I mean III that's it I'm gonna give you
my honest answer I think the baseball is
a little bit yeah I got baseball's what
is ya mean you know you know I don't
want to get so much into it I mean
because I don't want to discount the
players because I do think that the
players are bigger stronger faster than
they've ever been
there's an intent to release slug more
than there ever has been so you layer
that on with the baseballs I think the
obviously that's gonna lead to a bigger
number as well so juiced without saying
juiced is what is what we're talking
about but I I just can you tell the
difference is it physical where you can
hold it in if you bounce it is it the
sound of it leaving the bat I think that
in talking up is the feels different and
talking to hitters when they don't hit a
baseball as well as they think they
did and it goes a distance I'd you know
as a hitter you know when you get it and
you know when you don't but I've just
heard many times over when I didn't get
it and it carried you know ten seats
into the stands so that's just kind of
for me you hear that and you listen but
as far as the bouncing of the sound not
as much done yeah because I heard Rick
Sutcliffe talk about this and he's one
of the smartest guys I know when it
comes to pitching and he talked about
the seams that they're different than
they they've been before I don't know if
we're trying to create more offense here
it feels like every sport wants to
create more offense and baseball would I
guess be in life I missed the small
things in baseball Dave I really do like
your role nowadays in baseball I don't
know what that role would be it'd be
different but I miss the extra base I
miss you know hit and run I miss bunting
I like movement in the game you know
nobody's stealing you know 70 bases
anymore you know how do we get that back
do we need that back in baseball well I
think that that's a fair question and I
think for me the baseball peers that's
exactly what brought us to the game and
I think that you're talking about the
cerebral the thinking part of the game
the strategy part of the game that I
absolutely love but you know when
there's a so you know you're talking
about the audience that right now could
you argue that more people would would
rather see 100 mile an hour fastball and
450 foot homers than a sacrifice bunt or
a hit and run or throwing over three
times to have a guy steal second base I
mean I but for me were you for the
purist absolutely but I think that it's
talking about viewership sand I don't
complain about a three-hour game because
for me is is when there's a pitcher's
duel or when their strategies or
whatever it might be
Vulcan management matchups I I love that
stuff but I think that the general fan
these days I don't know if they would
say the same thing as you and I but
remember when you struck out a hundred
times Dave I mean you were no no not you
Paulie check and see how many times
though it's the most Dave Roberts struck
down disease
fact-check yeah but if you struck out
100 times in a season you were
embarrassed like you had the Scarlet
Letter on it now it's almost like that's
the Badge of Courage like oh you only
got punched out a hundred times I got
punched out a hundred and eighty seven
times you know Bryce Harper is one of
the best players in the game he's gonna
strike out 200 times this year how does
that happen yeah well I think that
there's there's a compensation part of
it where obviously these players are
getting compensated with Slug and that's
kind of equated to production you know
and where I do think that needle is
going to shift back
you see Cody Bellinger for example that
you'd mentioned earlier is shortening up
and use me on the part of the field and
I think that our guys in particular do a
really good job of minimizing the
strikeouts and one of the best players
one of the guys and I really love to
watch Mookie Betts he's one to one
strikeout to walk so there's guys in
there that they've got to make a
concerted effort to minimize the punch
but I still think that when game should
not make out that's the point of offense
and that's how you score runs we able to
reach out to Big Papi after what
happened to him in the Dominican
Republic no I'm gonna let the dust
settle as I know I've kind of heard
secondhand that that he's recovering
nicely and so yeah when the dust settles
I'm going to reach out to him it's just
very very sad unfortunate captain in his
own country so most importantly I'm
happy David recovered Pauly do you have
the most that Dave Roberts struck out in
a single yeah 2007 aged 35 with San
Francisco Giants Dave Roberts struck out
66 times but Dan he did it in four
hundred and forty three plate
appearances so if you prorated that to
six hundred plate appearances I got to
walk with that okay though or what I
know wait what is this Billy Beane here
that we care about you know you're I
know I know we don't need to talk about
my stats believer they're very
pedestrian that's okay okay but is there
one moment like one hitting moment that
will stand out not not stealing a base
we know that one
I hear that from you over and over and
over let me tell you about the stolen
base against the game you don't even say
hello you just I say hey Dave and you go
hey can I tell you about the stolen base
against the Yankee's yeah
what's the one hitting moment that
you'll tell your grandkids no I think
for me it's my first big-league hit you
know what's ironic is that Bobby Witt
jr. was a high pick obviously this year
and my first big hit big-league hit at
Tropicana Field was against his father
I'm gonna guess on the fastball it was a
high fastball that I got above and it
got a turned a single into a single into
a double left-center field yeah because
the if you have a base hit like your
first hit you don't want to get thrown
out at second yeah that's right you're
right yeah because then you or you get
picked off at first base you know hey I
got my first hit and then your leading
off and you're like you get picked off
Mike Hargrove the human rain delay hey
Congrats so far Congrats on the wine the
winning percentage and we appreciate
your time as always that's Dave Roberts
the Dodgers manager Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
they got the Diamondbacks coming up a
little bit later on today for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR Live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]